je m'appelle eddie brock je suis
journaliste
c'est plus fort que moi j' enquête
toujours sur des choses que la police
négligent
j'ai découvert quelque chose de vraiment
moche
et on peut dire que j'ai été dur qu'ils
arrêtent ce prix
lorsque vous observez ce monde que voyez
vous
planet kid au bord de l'implosion
les êtres humains sont insignifiants
combinant l'homme au symbiote à défaut
à l'aube tire une nouvelle race une
nouvelle espèce une forme de vie
supérieure qu'est-ce que tu attendes
mois aura bientôt
suis vraiment désolé
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut pas agressé tout le monde
regarde-moi aider voilà ce que j'en dis
on ne peut flairer
tout ce qu'on veut
on est d'accord une encre et attend de
gourmandise si peu de temps
ce pouvoir
mais pas totalement négatif
tu me fais vraiment pour la
rudy gobert
et peut-être que tu vis bras
les gars à votre page éviterait de faire
ça croyez moi
les grandes avancées
s'accompagne toujours de sacrifices